My name is Caucher Birkar. I'm a
professor of mathematics at the
University of Cambridge.
I think it's important to have something
original something authentic both in
mathematics and also generally in life. Because I believe that a lot of problem
in the world, social and political, arise
because people imitate other people,
because countries imitate other
countries. It's okay to learn from others,
to take ideas and to develop it. But it's
not good I think just to imitate others.
In algebraic geometry, geometric spaces
are called algebraic varieties and some
of them are more special than others.
Especially there are some of them which
are called final varieties and the one
of the building blocks of algebraic
varieties and what I proved is that if
you put some mild conditions on this
kind of varieties then you can
parameterize them by only finitely many
set of parameters. In a simple
language that just means that you need
only a fixed set of variables and
equations of a bounded degree to define
all such varieties.